kind of the ultra woke Brigade out there
they they categorize themselves as
liberals but there's nothing liberal
about that mentality when you have a
canceled culture which is driven by if
you don't agree with what I say you're
going to get shamed vilified canceled
fired maybe even in prison that is
actually what fascist regimes do to
people to their pockets yeah but the
fascists are more straightforward about
it because they basically come out and
say something like shut up or we'll beat
you right whereas the compassionate
types
who are narcissistic compassionate
compassionate types they come out and
say well we're really trying to save the
world you know and we're we're acting in
everyone's best interests and we think
it would be better if if you should just
you know regulate what you say because
if you don't you're not you're not a
good person
and so that's it's much more I'd take
the fascist bully over the narcissistic
over the compassionate narcissist any
time they're way more straightforward I
mean